you've deleted your Facebook account
good for you
I bet now you're probably wondering what
to do with yourself yeah don't worry
there's a lot you can do like share
photos of your baby in person my baby
baby photos put on my baby celebrate
friendship anniversaries we've been
friends six years today for you reach
out to people you went to high school
with hello hi this is Matt Baker we went
to high school together okay
yeah do you have any bikini pics jr. you
threw amusing memes that feeling when
you think it's Wednesday but it's really
Tuesday play candy crush like your
co-workers food ice salad like loudly
share their unwanted political views I
don't have a problem with immigrants and
of course willingly offer up your
personal information to strangers hey
here's my social security card that was
kind of a pain in the ass wasn't it yeah
kind of just makes you want to come back
to Facebook right yeah welcome back
dumbass
do you buy Facebook
[Applause]
you